so today I've been challenged by a guy
called fan bellows to go and visit 10
London landmarks in 2 hours
according to google maps at least this
should be completely possible so long as
I don't stop moving I really should have
waited until a day when it wasn't
raining
oh well naturally the first step is I'm
gonna get on a trade and actually go
into London so let's do that
[Music]
numero uno the Tower of London you know
there's crown jewels the Queen puts on
my head that's where they kept just in
there it also happens to be the place
where Anne Burrell in got her head
chopped off by a French man with a sword
usually they used to tend to do it with
axes that she was worried about having
an axe to her head because sometimes it
can take more than one slice of the axe
for a head to come off and so in the
hopes that she'd have a bit of a quicker
death she opted for the sword which is a
fun fact about execution there from me
neatly right next to the Tower of London
we have oh it's Tower Bridge the next
landmark I have a wire list is that
thing that's the shot fun fact about the
shard it's the tallest building in all
of the United Kingdom sort of I mean it
probably is but it's just not finished
yet and it won't be finished for another
couple of months I made it there we go
three down seven more to go this is fun
isn't it
meditation is
voiceover Charlie here at this point
London decided to get particularly wet
and windy which unfortunately means that
all of my footage sounds like this and
because I don't want you to have to
listen to that basically I found the
London Eye and that was good and then I
found Big Ben and that was also good and
then it started to be less windy fun
fact without Big Ben that tower thing
that you see there he's not actually Big
Ben what there's actually a bell inside
of that tower which is called Big Ben
but the tower itself is just called the
tower what I want to be able to say
right now is next up
Westminster Abbey I don't know where it
is I think it's over there I'm gonna get
that way I found it there it is whoa you
probably recognized Westminster Abbey
because it's the place where the recent
royal wedding happened how do you like
that
the next one's pretty darn cool forget a
10 Downing Street here unfamiliar with
the ways of the United Kingdom the coin
doesn't run the country we have another
man to do that it's called David Cameron
and he lives at 10 Downing Street
unfortunately that is as close as we're
gonna get to Downing Street today it's
just down there basically though I did
actually recently get to go beyond those
gates as things to work with Save the
Children handing in a charter to end
world hunger and so although I can't go
in there today here is a clip of me
waving dorkly hit front of 10 Downing
Street or your Heights why is London so
noisy we've got three more to go and
just over half an hour left I think we
could do this conveniently the next
one's right here this is Nelson's column
which is in Trafalgar Square oh yeah
next up bigger than the circus which i
think is just up here so here we are
Piccadilly Circus
as you can see filled with lots of
amazing bright lights everywhere wait
here we go there they are
awesome and then that's it cool the
thing about England is it's sort of like
America but I feel like everything in
England is just smaller so I think
Piccadilly Circus is a good symbol of
that we tried to do Times Square
but sort of got bored halfway through
and that's what we ended up with so long
as I haven't missed any landmarks which
I'm pretty sure I haven't we only have
one left now and there it is Buckingham
Palace salmon burrow
place of 11 minutes and 17 seconds to
spare I did all of the locations in
London and stuff there's a Union flag up
there flying high above the lovely
palace which means that the queen is on
the toilet I think but you know I'm max
hello max recognise me off youtube I
have a badge for you enjoy I wear with
pride cool thank you see ya thanks for
coming on this adventure with me bye
it'll all you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
wow look at that water droplet right on
the face look at her
brilliant